Aric Denson Hall you're the author of a
book called nelem confronting
high-profile attacks on celebrities and
businesses in your book who is being
nailed and who is doing the nailing the
American public has a long and healthy
history of witch hunts the American
public loves witch hunts that we have
for a very long time and generally
speaking the witches are people and
businesses and institutions that we
would like to blame for all of the
things that are going wrong with our
lives it is a lot of fun to see Bill
Gates get a pie in his face it's fun to
see Kathie Lee Gifford's flawless
marriage get exposed when very few of us
have flawless marriages it's fun to see
a big corporate chief get in trouble on
camera alleged to have made very
dangerous products we like in America a
democratic society seeing things evened
out and one of the reasons I called the
book nail them is I went for a run years
ago with a friend of mine who's a
reporter and I pointed to the house of a
prominent person in Washington and I
told him whose house it was and he was
working on the story and he said we're
gonna nail him and I said that's what
it's about with you in the press now
it's about nailing and he got very
defensive because the way the media
liked to think about attacks is we're
not attackers we are bringing about the
public's right to know and the way you
can justify any attack on anybody is by
using a phrase that's politically
correct such as unanswered questions if
you use the phrase unanswered questions
it allows you to do anything to any body
and sound like something other than a
thug if I were to pick up this coffee
cup and throw it at you that would be
considered mean and thuggish but if I
got on a camera and I said I am
protesting something that c-span did to
me it would sound very noble and the
American public likes the idea of
witch-hunts disguised as something very
noble why do they like witch-hunts I
think a lot of it has to do with two
things one is entertainment it's a lot
of fun to see a guy like Bill Gates get
in trouble it's a lot of fun to
speculate about what real
cause Tom Cruise and Nicole Kidman
marital breakup it's no fun to say that
the marriage broke up because in
Hollywood it's hard to keep a marriage
together it's much more fun to allege
that there's some dastardly sexual
things going on behind the scenes the
American public finds attacks
entertaining there is a resurgence or
not a resurgence and emergence of attack
programs NBC Dateline ABC 20/20 the
American public has a great thirst for
negative information because it's fun to
watch other people's dramas get caught
up when our lives might be by comparison
boring so to see a chief executive sweat
on camera to see Tom Cruise be accused
of being gay is very entertaining the
other component of it is in a democracy
we're very very big on keeping things
even when we look at somebody like Bill
Gates a lot of us say you know what I
don't know a lot about antitrust but he
has a hundred billion dollars and that's
too much money and in a democracy we
like seeing things evened out so if you
want to attack Bill Gates what are your
methods I think that there are several
methods one there are several methods of
attack that include you can sue you can
spread a rumor you can do an expose
alleging malfeasance or something
corrupt and don't get me wrong some of
the people who are accused of doing bad
things do bad things
what I find though is when we started
our business and what I'm in the
business of doing is trying to stop
these attacks and analyze who becomes a
cultural villain and why but what we
found is when we started the firm 15
years ago the chances are if you were
accused of doing something bad you did
it nowadays though a lot of the people
who come to us and a lot of the people
who are attacked really didn't do
something bad they did something that
offended the culture Kathy Lee Gifford's
great crime was probably having an all
too perfect marriage that she bragged
about too much to people's dislikes so
when she got in trouble for
manufacturing clothing using young
foreign labor it made it all all the
better but Kathy
givers perfect marriage is really not a
crime a la Watergate nowadays though
every civil rights violation is referred
to as another Holocaust every military
confrontation is referred to as another
Vietnam every scandal is called another
Watergate and quite frankly they're not
but we need them to be in order to
entertain us go back to Kathie Lee
Gifford
how was she nailed who nailed her and
why Kathie Lee Gifford was notorious for
getting on her TV show talking about her
perfect kids talking about her perfect
husband and people out in the heartland
are watching that and you know what
we're thinking we're thinking geez I
like my wife but not that much you know
and it sounds very terrible to say but
those of us who are married and who have
kids do not run through life in a
perpetual state of euphoria she seemed
to be what happened was the globe
newspaper
decided I think her marriage is a little
too perfect and I believe that it would
be worth an investment to prove that to
my readers they set up a woman in a
hotel room who had an affair with her
husband it was filmed and there before
mankind they revealed see what we told
you this marriage is not perfect they
made a business guess the globe did that
the public would be interested in and
guess what they guessed right sales were
up and the very same people who said I
really disapprove of what they've done
the proof is in the money follow the
money and the money said that the
American public was interested in it so
was she nailed and if she was was her
response adequate she was nailed in a
big way and and never fully recovered
from that and her response initially
made matters worse her response
initially was a denial that this is not
true there was one problem they had
videotape and when you have videotape
and you say to the American public this
is not true this didn't have not not
happen it becomes a problem
so eventually her response was right
which is to say on a very human level we
haven't we now have a problem and this
is a very difficult time for us and that
is what the American people want there's
a concept known as Shedden freud which
in german
enjoying the misfortune of others and
what we often want to see is somebody
screw up and admit that their lives are
flawed let's talk about another example
in your book Admiral excuse me Jeremy
border hmm that's a bit different what
happened there well at all boredom was a
man who had come into the military
ostensibly to clean up the Navy and lo
and behold a little while into his
tenure it was discovered that he wore
some medals on his uniform that may not
have been earned in the fashion that he
claimed well the media got all over this
there was no question that he was a
decorated Admiral but one of the medals
indicated service in Vietnam that the
technical definition of whether or not
it was earned was dubious an admiral
boorda went home one afternoon prior to
the release of a story in Newsweek and
he killed himself and it caused a lot of
uproar and the question is is was it
really that important to get the Admiral
well he was a very proud man and he
didn't want to bring further disgrace on
the navy in the aftermath of tailhook
and other scandals and he killed himself
now the question is is do you blame the
media for killing him well he was a
grown-up
he made his own choice but the debate
that it caused was wondering how deeply
do you have to investigate someone is it
really important nobody was
acknowledging that the medals were
totally false
they were acknowledging that the rules
were dubious under which he might have
won them but he killed himself is it
worth it is this a story that really
needed to be broken in your book you
break down these examples into what I'm
gonna call a text summary boxes so I
wanted to show that to our audience in
in this admiral boorda case you give the
date and then the players if you will
the victim you list as the US Navy the
villain admirable admiral boorda The
Vindicator the National Security News
Service the void was the validation of a
string of Navy scandals the vehicle
Newsweek
the value military integrity right
explain those roles every package has to
be it has to be every every attack has
to be packaged you need a villain a
victim and a Vindicator there needs to
be somebody who's hurt there needs to be
somebody who we say the media has to say
I'm doing this for you the American
people and the vid and the victim is the
villain is often a successful executive
a military leader an institution then
there has to be a victim such as the
American people who are supposedly being
hurt by this terrible villain how were
they hurt by boorda well I think that
that they were hurt in the sense that
the Navy had scandals and what the media
needed to do is say the reason why we
are going after the Admiral is because
the Navy and the military are bad bad
people and we have to expose the
horrible things that they're doing to
the public so you can't just go after
the Admiral and say we're doing it
because we're mean and we want a hot
story it doesn't work that way you have
to go after somebody by making it sound
noble and to be able to tell the
American people we are justifying this
investigation because of the American
public's right to know about scandals in
the military and that's where the role
of what I call the Vindicator comes in
and you had the Vindicator being certain
media people and military experts who
are ostensibly independent to come in to
prove to the world that this is
dangerous you can turn on the TV on any
given day and watch Dateline or a show
like that and you will see there is a
villain the evil businessman there is a
victim the person who was was rooked or
stolen from and then there is the
Vindicator an activist group or somebody
like that who says I'm just trying to
protect you and so that way you have a
story narrative that people like and it
has a logical conclusion and a beginning
and end just like a TV show after he
committed suicide
did the Navy still need someone like you
to help them with her reputation or was
the story just so sad that there was a
backlash well I think you're right in
that case there was a backlash because
nobody suspects their target to kill
themselves especially a man who by all
accounts was a very honest good person I
mean nobody ever accused
him of getting involved with sinister
things they accused him of wearing a
medal where the rules weren't clear
about whether he earned it he was later
vindicated by most sources and I think
that that really did backfire on the
news media as did the Richard Jewell
situation where he was accused of
blowing up the Atlanta Olympics when the
media screw up that way and they're
doing it more and more for reasons we
can get into there is a backlash but
when there's not a backlash make no
mistake about it the very same Americans
who say they do not like attack
journalism love it and the numbers prove
it talking about the media and the
culture of attack the recent election
and the events in Florida does any of
that tie in to how the media covered the
election I think so I mean I don't think
the backlash against the media was as
big as people say because where else are
we going to go for our news I mean when
a specific network is accused of messing
up they get in trouble but in this case
the whole media messed up and it's very
hard to punish them for that so what's
the price tag to me the interesting
thing about the election is who got
attacked and who survived and why a lot
of people kept talking about george w
bush not being very intelligent in my
experience one of the most important
factors in whether or not an individual
survives attack is whether or not we
like you and the American public does
not care how high your SAT scores work
that we really don't care
in fact if given the choice between a
president or a presidential candidate
who is dishonest and one that is
inconsistent we will choose someone who
is dishonest / someone who is
inconsistent one of the reason I'll give
you some examples people would often say
Ronald Reagan he's so dumb he doesn't
get his questions right but Ronald
Reagan was very consistent in who he was
George W Bush is no rocket scientist but
he is consistently a likable guy Bill
Clinton when we heard about Lewinsky one
of the reasons he got away with that is
because we were not learning anything
new
we knew this
about Bill Clinton when we elected him
this is the reason why a Democrat can
cheat on his wife while a Republican can
Republicans preach morality and if
you're going to preach morality don't
cheat on your wife
Bill Clinton basically communicated this
is the kind of guy I am
and the American public knew that was
the kind of guy he was and what and none
of us were shocked I want to ask you
about the Clinton situation you've got
in your appendix a section where you say
the headline is what Clinton's
operatives did right and you've got five
good moves listed and I wanted to talk
about I guess the first one good move
number one characterize the independent
counsels investigation as being about
sex how did that work well in any PR
battle a PR battle is not won by facts
it's won by values and emotions we don't
understand the public doesn't appreciate
facts we understand basic human
vulnerability and values to educate the
public about the law which is what a lot
of what the Ken Starr and everybody
tried to do nobody understands that
nobody understands statutes and perjury
and things like that what we all know
universally is none of us want to have
our sex lives investigated for whether
or not we're doing something wrong or
doing something right we don't like it
and the brilliance of that maneuver is
no matter how many times Clinton was
accused of legal crimes which he did
nobody got it because it wasn't sexy and
it's hard to understand I mean nobody
really understands that Al Capone was
caught for income tax evasion people
don't understand that most businessmen
who get in trouble don't get in trouble
for the core crime they get in trouble
for mail fraud or wire fraud which means
that they used the phone to do illegal
stuff the brilliance of what Clinton's
people understood is that the law
doesn't photograph well nobody gets it
but people do get sex and by constantly
hammering on that theme most people came
back and said you know what it's a
personal matter we don't want to we
hear about it insofar as we want to be
entertained but I don't think he should
lose his job because of it that's how
the public ruled good move
number to mobilize the first lady you
bet the Clintons are like those cartoon
characters who when they're hit by
lightning gets stronger the among the
only people I've ever dealt with or
David I don't deal with them but I've
ever analyzed them who actually gets
stronger when you attack them and why I
think that a lot of it has to do with
women in America being able to identify
with a woman who is a victim of
something there is a victim ethic and
when Hillary Clinton campaigns on a
platform she never does well she loses
but when she is a victim she is very
very powerful there is something very
compelling about her under siege and
striking back at her enemies it becomes
it becomes a Hollywood drama is this
something in her personality or is this
something her PR handlers are
recommending I feel a victim well I
think that a lot of it is her and her
own skills
I think Clinton's PR people are very
good but there is something about how
she is able to get out and say I am
under it's very unattractive attacking a
woman first of all it sounds very sexist
but whether it's lazio walking up to her
at the podium there is something in our
culture even if in this interview if I
were to start yelling at you on camera
and moving closer and closer to you the
audience would be offended because the
idea of a man invading a woman's space
is is culturally offensive and the idea
of rich white Republicans attacking
Hillary Clinton even if she's guilty is
very culturally offensive so I think
it's her not her handlers did the same
go for Monica Lewinsky because she was a
woman she was seen more as a victim I
think that in our culture and given who
the type of people are who are in the
news media
it's very palatable to make women
victims even when they're not there is
this notion that anything a man does is
somehow predatory and anything a woman
does is somehow soft
and a function of victimhood I don't
think however monica lewinsky was a
terribly sympathetic character largely
because even the most feminist oriented
people in the world did not believe that
clinton of his own free will had a
one-way assault on her she clearly
behaved in ways that were not terribly
sympathetic which i think helped him
good move number three pre leaking the
president's reversal on having sex with
Lewinsky why was that a good move I
think it was a good move because for
Clinton to have come out and have been
the first one to have said oh by the way
I lied that's a problem it's a very very
unappealing type of thing and what has
to happen is something that we call in
the crisis management business
inoculation to the extent you can be an
inoculation and medicine is injecting
the virus into the human body so you're
used to it the more you have people talk
about it it is less shocking when the
key figure comes up and says I messed up
because by the time you hear about it
you've already heard about it so Clinton
purposely wanted Lewinsky's name to be
in all the papers oh I oh I don't think
that he wanted the story to break but
once you know it's going to break you
might as well be the ones to break it
and I don't think that that that he
broke the fundamental of Winsky story
what he broke was his reversal in his
point of view which was that he lied he
was not the one the first one to come
out and say that his handlers did who
did break the Lewinsky story well
depending upon who you believe it's a
toss-up between Matt Drudge Newsweek and
the Washington Post news weeks Michael
Isikoff had done the hard work but
Drudge had broken it and once something
is out there I mean there's an old kind
of disgusting saying that it's hard to
put the manure back in the donkey and I
think once it was out they had no choice
but to respond to it good move number
four blowing up Afghanistan and Sudan
yeah I think that if ever wag the dog is
something that usually only works in the
movie but there is something very
appealing about when you're under siege
finding a bigger crisis I mean one way
to handle the cry
as well is to give your attacker a
bigger crisis or create a diversion and
when we are at war nobody wants to hear
about sex and it was a good move for
Clinton to attack Afghanistan and Sudan
because it diverted the news cycle to
terrorism and I think was largely
effective do you really think the reason
he he took those actions was in direct
response to Lewinsky I mean is it a
linear decision you bet I know could I
ever prove that not in a million years
but I think that the fact is is only one
story can be the top news was wag the
dog before the Lewinsky the dog came out
somewhat before not the Lewinsky scandal
but before Afghanistan and Sudan and in
fact they came out at roughly the same
time the truth is is one of things
that's interesting about that movie is
it has made this spin doctor into a
cultural icon and quite frankly very few
of us are as effective as you can be in
a movie there is a great belief nowadays
that if you hire the right spin doctor
like Robert De Niro's character Conrad
Brean and wag the dog that he can do
anything in the real world there there
are other explanations Clinton did not
survive because of spin he survived
because number one people liked him
number two nobody was surprised and
number three we had a Dow Industrial
Average at 10,000 for the first time in
history what's to impeach let's talk
about spin-doctors cuz you're number
five good move number five says press
secretary
McCurry Mike McCurry kept plausible
denial what did Mike McCurry do right
well it wasn't just what Mike McCurry
did right it was what the people around
him did right Mike McCurry is a very
very gifted communicator he's also a
pretty honest guy and very effective at
what he did if he were to be in the loop
at every step of the way he would have
been in a position was where he would be
misleading the press if he genuinely
didn't know much like Pierre Salinger
during the Cuban Missile Crisis
genuinely didn't know he wouldn't be
lying and it allowed it allowed McCurry
to come out of that without ever having
been accused of being dishonest because
there were things that he truly did not
know now he ultimately expressed disgust
with with with what was done to him but
no
ever accused McCurry of knowingly and
willfully leading misleading people and
what you have in a crisis is a tension
between the PR people and the lawyers
the lawyers don't want you to say
anything and the PR people do the
lawyers were clearly in charge does that
type of tension between PR and lawyers
apply to businesses that are under
attack and give us an example your book
is replete with businesses that have had
situations where they've been under
attack tylenol Pepsi valujet Eli Lilly
on the prozac Mike Ovitz take one of
those and walk us through how and how
that tension relates the lawyers it is a
lawyers job to keep things out of the
press so that nothing in a court can be
brought and thrown back in their clients
face an attorney is correct to want
their client to be quiet however a
communicator is correct for want their
client to talk if I came on your show
and you said to me Eric my laptop
computer was out there did you steal it
and I said I'm not gonna tell you your
response is you're guilty and your
viewers would look at that and say this
guy stole your laptop however from us so
from a legal perspective I shouldn't
comment but from a PR perspective I
should the answer to the question should
be no I didn't do it or yes I did do it
by now I needed to borrow it because you
have to be able to pass the red faced
test I think you see a lot of people who
are under attack who come out with
answers and descriptions that are
ludicrous when House Speaker Wright was
indicted years ago for his book deal he
said I welcome the indictment who in
their right mind welcomes an indictment
nobody but there are certain things
lawyers tell you to say that you
shouldn't say that work in court but
don't work in the court of public
opinion and I think a lot of corporate
crises there is a tension between the
law department that says do not get out
in front of the cameras and valujet you
had a lot of turret ernie's out there
saying don't don't talk to the press
we're gonna get sued but the CEO to his
credit said you know what we have held
for a hundred people who died I am going
to talk to the press I don't care what
the legal consequences are because what
people feel about me as a human being
will reflect upon this company and if I
stand up here and say no comment we are
guilty as a crisis manager yourself do
you tend to end up on the side of the
lawyers or on the side of the PR folks
or neither generally speaking we are
retained associated with legal cases so
we have a real sensitivity to the
lawyers argument it is my preference
that a company under attack is able to
convey some human concern however I
reject what I often hear from the media
which is we have a right to see your
clients files it's not unusual for us to
get a call from some 25 year old
producer that says let me see everything
you've got and the answer is no and the
reporter often responds by saying we
have a right to see that material
they're under the impression that they
have a constitutional right to destroy
my client so in that sense I empathize
with the attorneys but where I disagree
with the attorneys is there's no comment
business does not serve serve us very
very well because in our culture it is
not guilt that convicts
it's suspicion and the longer you wait
to reply the more you're going to be
accused of doing a terrible thing
because guilt it's suspense that
convicts not guilt let's look at another
example who have a corporate corporation
under attack if you will and your attack
summary box and we've got a situation
where Pepsi Cola in June 1993 had a
victim which was consumers a villain
Pepsi Cola a Vindicator consumers who
discovered syringes void was attention
money confirmation that big companies do
bad things the vehicle media coverage
and the value public safety walk us
through this example what happened in
the case of Pepsi is suddenly all across
the country people were finding syringes
supposedly in their Pepsi cans Pepsi
obviously was upset about that the
question becomes what do you do well
there's good news and bad news
the bad news is nobody likes an
allegation that there's a syringe in
your Pepsi the good news though is the
American public is very intuitive and
they ask themselves the question
what incentive would a soft drink
company possibly have to put syringes in
their drinks and the answer is none so
there is common sense involved there is
common sense I mean as opposed to men
manufacturing it is conceivable that a
company could manufacture a flawed
product but why would a company allow
something like this to happen that
crisis stopped with one visual image and
what was discovered was a store camera
showed a woman after the story first
broke taking the syringe and dropping it
into a camera very secretly they had
evidence and what that confirmed for the
public was what you were dealing was
with was me two crimes and we see these
all the time if one person probably
slipped it in saw something on the
internet or ro or on television and said
hey that's a way for me to make money to
let me put a syringe in so Pepsi did
several things that were right one of
them was lucky
the store camera that showed the syringe
had nothing to do with them but it was a
brilliant turn because we showed the
public a visual image that was that was
an alternative and when I say we it
wasn't me I mean Pepsi did this
themselves it had nothing to do with me
but people fundamentally understood that
the second thing they did right is I
don't know whether you've ever been in a
soft drink plant but they released video
footage showing how soft drinks are made
and when you see thousands of cans
whirring at the speed of light it is
impossible for this to happen and the
public looked at this visual and said
how could this happen well it can't
happen the third thing that was done
correctly is the Food and Drug
Administration came out and said we see
no evidence that this is true so on a
variety of fronts they did the right
thing and they also had a very effective
leader a man named Craig weather up who
was at the time running Pepsi who said
who was a sort of a your favorite
science teacher and he was way out in
front and generally speaking in a crisis
situation the chief executive officer
has to become the chief crisis officer
they took direct responsibility they
were out front they were out front very
quickly and we asked ourselves the same
question that they do when they review a
they would script who do we like here we
like Pepsi because they were behaving in
a way that was obviously right and moral
and they also had have we also noticed
the we mean in the American public that
there was a bad guy there was a bad
person sticking syringes and Pepsi's we
love it when clients are attacked by
terrorists because of the easiest crises
to get out of because nobody wants them
to win
how was Pepsi affected their sales ever
drop off initially yes but they were
they recovered in a matter of weeks they
were not permanently hurt at all but
there were a few weeks of disruptions
they did pull the materials off the
shelves and they there were short-term
losses but that's what crisis management
is all about how about valujet did they
recover no why not valujet first of all
you had a more serious crisis you had a
hundred and ten people or so died and a
lot of whether or not you get out of a
crisis is tied to whether or not people
die and then in the Pepsi case nobody
did and valujet you had things go people
go down there's also the one of the
things that determines whether or not
you get out of a crisis is who is
perceived to have caused it it was very
clear in the case of valujet that a lot
of things were done wrong in terms of
how they handled not the crisis but how
they handled running their airline there
were vendors who were sticking oxygen
canisters on board this is clearly bad
and negligent did the public know that
before the accident before the accident
no but afterwards it came out
immediately that sloppy things were done
and the other thing that's a problem is
when you have an airline called value
jet do you really if given the choice
between value and going down in the
Everglades you know you don't want so
much value after that and ultimately the
best thing that valujet did in in
addition to fact to immediately managing
the crisis from the top they ultimately
changed their name there is no more
value jet and I think that that was the
right decision because it's very hard
contrary to what you hear I mean the
conventional thinking in PR circles is a
crisis is an opportunity no it's not
crises are bad
cancer is bad getting hit by a car is
bad it's best to move on if you can and
they changed their name to other
corporate persona play a role in your
book that I want to mention one is
Dwayne Andreas and one is Mike Ovitz who
is Dwayne Andreas Dwayne Andreas was the
CEO of Archer Daniels Midland and they
came under attack because of terrible
legal problems that the company had with
price-fixing and things like that what
made matters worse is they were
positioned as very secretive and were
rather arrogant here you have a company
that was called the super market to the
world and they were engaging in
stridently illegal behaviors and at the
same time they were making public
statements such as the world can't run
without us the American public gets very
and law enforcement by the way we don't
like the idea that the world can't run
without me the idea of one person having
that much power is a problem and even
though law enforcement went after them
for other reasons the American public
and journalists are looking at this and
they're saying who is this one company
that believed their supermarket to the
world that scares us and consequently
they were brought down not only for
legal reasons but because the appearance
that one person had this kind of power
was a good provocation for the media to
look into everything they had ever done
hindsight is 20/20 but if Dwayne Andreas
had called you eight years ago and said
come work for me
be my crisis manager what would you said
well for the record I was I don't work
with them but number one when you engage
in price-fixing and you have some
psychotic executive who is actively in
stridently engaging in price-fixing well
advice number one is don't be involved
with price-fixing because you know the
fundamental crisis has nothing to do
with it being mismanaged but if you if
you engage in criminal ways that will
bring about problems second I think
you've got to really watch the arrogance
there is nothing more disturbing to
American audiences than the idea that
one guy is quietly pulling all the
strings that are making the world
and even though I think he was smart to
befriend presidents world leaders and
things like that there was sort of this
mystique this Wizard of Oz there's a man
behind the curtain running everything
and he liked that and the company liked
that they played it up the other thing
they played up is fear when I first came
to Washington I I didn't know who Archer
Daniels Midland was and somebody said oh
you're doing your writing about them
don't ever mess with them mess with them
why would I want to mess with them but
fear only gets you so far and because
sooner or later you're gonna find an FBI
agent or a reporter that's gonna go you
know what
I'm not afraid let me see if I can take
them I mean reporters and law
enforcement people love to be threatened
because they're in a position where they
can do something about it and the
arrogance is what hurt Michael Ovitz
Michael Ovitz is a brilliant power
broker in Hollywood he was the head of a
company called Creative Artists Agency
he was widely regarded and listed on
these silly power lists that they do as
the most powerful man in Hollywood
something that he apparently liked he
was always ranked number one well the
good news for ovis is they were he was
amazingly effective for his clients the
bad news is when you are in Hollywood a
town where everybody wants to see you
fail to go around saying I'm more
powerful than anybody now I know he
never directly said it but it was very
much advertised that he was the most
powerful a lot of his routines the fact
that he got up in five o'clock in the
morning and practiced martial arts there
was this zen-like mystique those who
mess with him will be gunned down on the
street there was some comment attributed
to him where he apparently said if you
mess with me my foot soldiers on
Wilshire Boulevard will gun you down
well here you have the same phenomenon
as Andreas in a town full of huge egos
there is supposedly one guy
single-handedly running everything
people wanted to kill him I mean you
have Geffen you have Wasserman you have
Eisner Spielberg Katzenberg and one guy
is solely responsible for running all of
Hollywood they wanted to bring him down
and eventually they did is it more
dangerous to be visible like a Mike
Ovitz or
guess Dwayne Andreas was only after the
fact or I'm thinking you have a quote on
page 58 where you say no one associates
corporations with real people is it sort
of safer if you're working for a company
to be at tylenol where the executives
are invisible they're not like a Mike
Ovitz where they're out getting PR what
do you recommend to your clients to keep
a high profile a low profile or is it
case-by-case it depends what business
you're in for somebody like Donald Trump
he is in the business of casinos he's in
tourism business so for him to get on TV
talking about being the richest man in
the world sure it's obnoxious but you
know it's smart business because that's
what he's selling he's selling flesh
he's selling mystique he's a smart guy
the question becomes if you're the CEO
of a pharmaceutical company you don't
need to be a rock star and the problem
with what's happening in today's media
culture is everybody wants to be a rock
star they want to be on the cover of a
magazine and the question becomes is
this necessary I think for somebody like
Ovitz he probably went too far is it
really important for somebody who is
fundamentally a talent agent to be on
the cover of magazines I'm not so sure
that it is because what happens is the
minute you appear on the cover of a
magazine whether you're a legitimate
business executive or a mobster they
want to take you down and what I say to
clients is if there is a business reason
to raise your profile do it but if it's
all about ego you're gonna get nailed
let's go back to your company
sure is your company successful the
company is successful we have a strange
niche we represent clients under attack
we represent clients who are modern-day
witches that people want to burn and the
modern-day witches are not just
individuals but they're big companies
people love the notion that a soft drink
or a food item is dangerous these are
our cultures witches and nowadays they
can do they are they turn on the
internet in the morning they go on the
internet and they're being accused of
all kinds of heinous things that they
didn't do
somebody needs to fight back that's what
we do do your clients find you or do you
seek out them when you see an attack
they find us it's hard to
ambulance-chasing our business because
there's something rather unseemly about
it but what happens is there's not a lot
of people who do what we do it's a
strange business and there's not a lot
of people who have written books about
this exact topic so they tend to seek us
out when they're tired of being
assaulted
why are you based in DC and not New York
or California a lot of it is we like DC
there's usually a political implication
to what we do we're not a political firm
we don't rip or not Democrat versus
Republican but there is always a policy
implication if somebody wants to come
after a consumer product company there's
going to be a lawsuit attached and
there's going to be legislation attached
in Washington is a good place to be for
that do you have a law degree I don't
have a law degree no but we oh we are
frequently teamed with lawyers and
lobbyists to deal with this problem
these problems and a lot of the clients
that come under attack are ultimately it
ends up on Capitol Hill especially
nowadays with the internet because the
Internet has become Dodge City for
attacks if you want to attack somebody
years ago if I wanted to spread a rumor
about you I'd have to go to Woodward and
Bernstein they would investigate that
would take months they may or may not
run with it nowadays if I didn't like
you I could spread a cyber rumor call
the flame and destroy you or hurt you in
two seconds do your clients ask that you
not reveal that fact that you've been
hired yes the the fact that we have been
hired is considered sometimes to be
material to the marketplace and what I
mean by that is it could affect stock
price there are certain cases that are
in the public domain that I can talk
about most of them I can't because if
you were too hot to say to the world I
worked for the Acme food company
suddenly the Acme food company has let
the world know that they have a crisis
which could affect their stock price it
could also signal their attackers that
they're vulnerable and I don't want the
people who we are looking at as possible
is what we call hostels to know that I'm
looking at them do you have a PR person
at your company well we have a lot of PR
people people with PR backgrounds we
don't have people who promote the firm
per se because we don't really want to
want it known I mean I do a lot of media
interviews and I can tell you case
studies but what I can't do in all cases
is name the individual clients
you worked in the Reagan White House
what was your job there I was a really
young guy and my job in the early 80s
was I was one of these young guys in the
basement who picked up the phone in the
media relations office and said here's
what the president meant because Ronald
Reagan was notorious for making comments
that flew out there and there were a lot
of people who handled that and what I
what I did one of the things I learned
from that experience is you are dealing
a lot of times not with communications
problems but with conflicts the media
just didn't like Reagan they didn't like
him and one of the things Reagan's
people always understood is that
whenever Reagan talked to the press he
lost whenever he talked to the American
heartland he won and that was basically
our job who do you want to read this
book I think that anybody who is
interested in modern-day witch-hunts
should read the book anybody who was
interested in why the American culture
loves to attack anybody who was
concerned that they may be attacked and
how you defuse attacks would be
interested in the book do you want
corporate leaders to read it oh yeah
that it's biggest audience is with
corporate leaders who are sick and tired
of being right and losing what's your
next book the next book is a novel that
deals with a disgraced pollster who is
recruited by organized crime to help
with their misunderstood image it deals
with the spin at its most despicable and
it shows how in our modern day times you
with a modem and motive you could ruin
anybody if you've got the right spin
doctor what do you like better
nonfiction or fiction well I think
non-factor I think fiction is more fun
because you can go wild and you can make
up cases I mean I'm talking in the case
of the fiction book about how the Mafia
would it would manipulate the media I
have no reason to believe that the Mafia
is particularly effective at it but I
think the American culture loves the
notion of some of the tough guys I grew
up around in Jersey what would happen if
if Tony Soprano got himself a pollster
what kind of damage could he do and
that's basically what I talk about in
the book when's it out end of the year
Eric Denson mall near the author
currently of Nahum confronting
high-profile attacks on celebrities and
businesses published by Prometheus books
thank you for joining us thanks for
having me